we're to talk about in this video is how
political and cultural events might have
an influence on someone's political
ideology so let's make this a little bit
concrete and political scientists will
sometimes have various classifications
for these types of effects so for
example there's something known as
generational effects and these would be
events that affect an entire generation
that could influence how an entire
generation thinks about their position
on different issues an example of that
might be if you were to grow up or if
you were an adult during the Great
Depression in the 1930s
well that might affect you in many many
different ways you would start to maybe
be a little bit conservative with their
own personal finance is realizing that a
rainy day might come one day many people
who grew up during the Great Depression
viewed FDR Franklin Roosevelt as a major
factor in taking the country out of the
Great Depression other folks might
disagree with that position but if you
were one of those folks who believed
that FDR through the expansion of
government helped bring the country out
of the Great Depression and if you
believe that FDR was a good leader for
the United States during World War two
well then you might lean democrat you
might lean Democrat the rest of your
life and it indeed seems to be the case
that many people who grew during the
Great Depression
did indeed lean Democrat because of
their belief that FDR was good for the
country similarly if you grew up during
the Cold War if you were an adult during
the Cold War you had this thing hanging
over you in the 60s 70s and 80s of what
would a nuclear war with the Soviet
Union look like and so many of those
folks might look at someone like a
Ronald Reagan who many people would
argue helped bring about the end of the
Cold War and so many of these folks who
did view Ronald Reagan as a major actor
there might lean a Republican or even if
they don't mean Republican they might
say hey the type of strong muscular
military presence with diplomacy that
Ronald Reagan did well that's a type of
point of view that I support now these
two things were
macro events that would have happened
over many many years if not decades but
there could also be particular events
and sometimes particular political
events that might influence someone's
political ideology so let me write this
down political political events and so
an example of that might be the
Watergate scandal under Richard Nixon
many of the people who were adults then
and understood what was going on it
might have led to a general distrust in
government it might have led to a more
of a belief that people in high office
do things without telling us once again
these are not it's not going to be
everyone who lived in that time period
but it might make some folks lean one
direction or another now everything I've
talked about has been in the realm of
politics but there's also a lot that
happens in culture that could affect
your ideology if you see more of a
certain point of view on television for
example or in movies that might make you
more sympathetic to that point of view
you also have effects over the course of
your life that affect your ideology and
so these are often known as lifecycle
effects life cycle effects and this is
the idea that as you go from being young
to getting older just different things
in your life might make you lean in one
direction or another these are going to
be broad generalizations but let's say
you are young you are in college you
have a lot of student debt you might
lean a maybe towards a more progressive
candidate or have liberal leanings if a
candidate saying hey the government's
going to try to reduce student debt or
provide more support for young students
but then as you get older and maybe you
become a homeowner maybe you have more
wealth you're have a higher income you
might say hey these taxes really hurt
more than I suspected and they're quite
large or maybe you're starting a
business and you're saying hey these
regulations really aren't as good as an
idea as I thought they were when I was
young well then maybe you might and I'd
stress might you might start lean more
conservative so I'll leave you there the
big picture is is that your political
ideology isn't just driven
your genetics or your family and we've
talked about these in other videos or
where you grow grew up so not just
driven by geography it's driven by a
whole set of things many of the things
that might happen to you individually
let's say you you had a bad incident
with a with crime that might make you
tougher on crime or maybe you're on the
other side you got arrested for
something you didn't do that might
change your point of view
and things that happen on a bigger scale
things that might happen to your entire
generation